[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay guys come on get a move on we're
going on soon ah Hiroyuki Carter hey
call me hero pleasure to meet you I was
beginning to think you and your driver
weren't gonna make it
I'm from live the camera company
sponsoring this race and I'll be heading
up this event walk with me look thanks
again I'm really stoked about this
thanks for giving us this shot
don't mention it we're always on the
lookout for new talent and you and your
friend fit the bill and I don't have to
tell you this but do you do right for
yourselves in this race
you'll see a lot of doors opening up for
you gotcha we won't disappoint you
disappoint me that's not what this is
about it's your chance to impress people
who matter the events my company
organizes are a feeder for every racing
family out there you do want to raise
yeah
oh yeah this is such a big deal for us
you try broadcasting the races but no
dice I guess nobody wants to see
nobody's trust me just show the world
what you've got this one
you'll get followers like that run a
good race you'll find your options and
your followers increasing we'll give it
our best here on my friend I don't want
your best
I want legendary badass stuff anyway
I've got to go something about putting
on a race best of luck
okay thanks
you're good to go buddy break a leg help
break anything you have to
drive like I know you can and will
it's in no time
you
welcome to the city that never sleeps in
this event you'll see New York taken
over by racers in a way you never could
have imagined it's not just the city
it's a playground for the best pilots
and drivers of today and tomorrow
we're here today to watch the first
episode of this year's live extreme
series in this new season talented
newcomers have a shot of taking on
established stars and a chance to
impress all the racing teams out here
and believe me they're watching and just
as important they need to generate
excitement that's how fans flock to them
and that's what it's all about right
become a racer steal the show and see
your follower numbers sort
speaking of soaring get a load of that
jump there you have it folks the numbers
are going through the roof
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and now live-- goes to the extreme
your game followers by winning of course
but that's not the only way do a
spectacular stunt like this and the fans
will come a-runnin check it out
we're two-thirds of the way through and
I believe we're watching a new star
exploding onto the circuit
we kick it up a notch for their grand
finale
[Music]
this is how it is these days just being
a good pilot isn't enough anymore
you've got to shine on and off the
course staying sharp on the social media
side
it's simple math the more followers you
have the more followers you'll get sign
on with your first racing team and the
second will start looking at you pile up
supporters and the contracts will be
knocking on your door to put it another
way a driver who attracts enough
followers will open up new styles of
racing we call them disciplines y'all
call them awesome and isn't awesome what
we're all after
from the heart of New York City this was
the live extreme series episode one
thank you for watching and remember to
follow us on all social media
you
[Music]
cool it is official my friend we have
made the big time we're still gonna have
to prove ourselves but that's more than
fine you know we got the right stuff
there's so much to try folks planes all
kinds of cars it's like the world's
biggest buffet menu and we gonna take a
bite out of everything we're talking
street racers off-road pro racing
freestyle we can take a test run with
any of them or if you asked me do them
all pick which one you want to try first
let's go my friend
welcome to the motor nation now we've
got four ways we can get this puppy
rolling it's your pick how do you want
to start